luke tom and nate here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today
we are going to be hiking camping
fishing
we're here in whittier alaska hopefully
if all goes well
we are gonna get to camp by the ocean
and do some surf fishing
and uh not get eaten by bears are you
guys excited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah is that doing okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you okay
it rains a ton here and we're actually
really lucky the weather's perfect today
[Music]
jump under the law check this out this
is devil's club you know why they call
it devil's club
look at all those spikes yes and it's
got a poison in it so if it scratches
you it makes it makes it burn really bad
we probably should have brought our
fishing boots it is so much mud isn't
there
yeah mud does look like chocolate
pudding here tom give me your hand
now scoot across nope nope nope okay
yeah nathan stepped in that mud and he
like disappeared
some more blueberry bushes white
blueberries these are blueberries
i only have one too yeah yeah sure oh
they're vital blueberries
but look at this these are all blueberry
bushes right
[Music]
oh you here a watermelon berry yeah
we're here in late july and there are
berry bushes
everywhere we've got salmon berries
blueberries
watermelon berries yeah that one's not
ripe yet though
yeah check this out this is a good one
here
go for it that means you want to eat
that i eat this
yeah it tastes good
that's gorgeous yeah stay close nathan
there's a lot of bears here
i brought along a can of bear spray uh
in case we run into any bears
also a lot of people will tell you to
make noise when you're on the trail
this is an unnecessary thing when hiking
with nathan and tom
see check that out guys bear poop
that's black bear poop okay now find a
rock you can kneel down on without
getting muddy and super wet
okay look up your backpack
all that tastes good this is the
lifestraw
it's a filter that allows you to drink
water in the wilderness safely
and they're a few bucks and they're
really light and so i just give them to
each one of the kids and then they can
drink out of the streams
[Applause]
see we're just walking along the coast
trying to get to a deserted cove
[Music]
we gotta cross this little creek
[Music]
give me your hand there you go
[Music]
nathan are you ahead
yeah it looks like the bridge broke
it's butter dad yeah it was way quick
oh look at that cliff
this is shark skin
yeah so careful yeah
i got wet but the boys want a little
backpack break
oh how you guys doing you buddy yeah
everything about this hike is wet and
muddy even this
beautiful little field is soggy look at
this
see
it's hard to even find a spot to sit or
put your backpack down
that isn't covered in water and mud
careful you don't want to fall down that
step like a ladder onto these roots
okay
well this is the first real hike where
the boys have had to carry a significant
pack
and they've done really well it's about
five miles but uh their shoulders are
hurting so we're taking
turns having me carry one of their packs
that seems to help them
give them a little encouragement the
hard part is that i've got two of them
so if both of them poop out on me it's
really hard to carry both of their packs
in mine
but uh they're doing real good so far
imagine being a bear
oh you find crowberries strawberries
yeah
yeah there's a little crowberry
i see the bristle right look at that i
can see a cove over there
look at this oh look there's like a
little island
no this is a nice place to camp are you
relaxing
let's explore a little bit check it out
guys
hey guys check it out this is a
bladderwort
trap of edible
do you think of seaweed yeah see that's
a sea urchin right there guys
did you climb all the way up there yeah
you want some help getting down
you don't need any help of course you
don't
oh well this looks like a nice spot
to camp we're up high enough that i
think we'll be dry even at high tide
you can see the seaweed marks uh where
they've had more recent high tides
and we've got a little bit of flat
ground here yeah i think we might be
okay
plus uh these rocks are a good place to
focus for fish so
we might actually get lucky with a
little surf fishing
the kids are really hungry as they
should be
so we are going to go ahead and just pop
open
some some of this granola because it
doesn't take any cooking
find that plant in this book there you
go
blueberry granola cut on your head
here
big tangle of stuff here
look at that light up
well the boys have been playing while i
got the tent pitched and the fire
started and tommy over there
is just popping limpets as fast as he
can are you eating limpets
yeah minnie lippin i i only ate
one you only eat one little bit
all right boys you want lasagna or beef
stew
all right beef stew it is
i must open my knife
okay there you go buddy wait i want to
eat
everything we have
[Music]
all right frozen chunk of herring here
now i've been telling the boys that the
best skipping rocks in the world
are here in whittier
we're gonna hop off into the woods here
a little bit and try to get
some fresh berries and water
are those right yeah if they're soft
between your fingers
and they fall off the bra or the bush
really easy they're ripe
all right come on let's keep walking
yeah that's a good bush salmon berry
bush
[Music]
you okay nathan oh yeah that's what
what that's a beauty
place with water actually
knock the number thing down here
oh here's some good ones oh
yeah here we go got some water phew
i've got the six liter bladder i'm going
to fill up with water
and i've got this chlorophloc it kills
bacteria and viruses
and it makes any solids and yucky stuff
in the water fall out
once you've mixed the chlorophyll and
the water
you shake it up for like one minute
straight
there you go
oh
we made it back
you see how the water's kind of changing
color it's getting a little bit lighter
if we let it sit all this stuff will
start to settle to the bottom
all right should we get you out of your
wet clothes there in cup you can
oh
i've never seen so much water in such a
little shoot
[Music]
there you go put all the boys clothes up
on this log to dry downwind from the
fire
there you go the water's looking pretty
good the chlorophyll
has knocked a big layer of mud to the
bottom
whoa that fills the whole thing up yeah
that's a lot of berries guys
let's get the boys beds all made up
i'm really stoked for the kids to use
these uh new big agnes sleeping bags i
bought them
this one's the wolverine and that one's
the little red and it fits tommy and
nathan
perfectly and these are 15 degree mummy
bags
from a good reputable company and they
have a sleeve
on the bottom so that their mat inserts
into their sleeping bag and they can't
roll off their their
mat i'm going to be trying out a brand
new air mattress today this is the sea
to summit comfort light
it's not a self-inflating
mat but the bag is a pump
put it in like this pump up the sack
and then we just squeeze
the sack and it inflates it
i can't make it
all right we're gonna have a little
lasagna before bed here
you've got so much on your face
yeah my brother loaned me this can of
bear spray and uh
i think it's over 20 years old i believe
we bought this when we were teenagers
but i've never actually sprayed this
i've carried cans
many times and i know people who've had
to use it on bears
but i've never used it i think i'm gonna
test it just you know see what happens
we're gonna get downwind a bit got this
little
safety right there and
well there you go it's 20 years old and
it still works doesn't go that far i'd
say maybe
15 feet 20 feet with the wind at your
back
man you don't want to get this stuff in
your face i had a friend once who tested
a can of
mace while sitting in my car it wasn't
fun
this is what 9 p.m in alaska looks like
but
the boys are tuckered out and it's past
their bedtime so we're getting them in
their beds and we're going to get them
all asleep
i really don't want to rebuild the fire
tomorrow morning so i want it to last
all night long so i've piled up a bunch
of wood
covered in wet seaweed and put up some
wind blocks and just tried to smother it
so that it's
slow roasting down there and hopefully
there'll be lots of coals come tomorrow
well nathan has already completely
zonked out so we're gonna let him rest
and me and tommy are gonna watch some
movies on our phone aren't we buddy
i was sitting in bed and almost asleep
and i start hearing splashing
there's pink salmon jumping jumping all
over this cove
salmon aren't in love with still bait
out in the ocean our lure would really
be better but
let's give it a shot and see what
happens
[Music]
i lost three rigs and caught only a
starfish so i think that's a sign that's
not time to go back to bed
good morning nathan
putting the shoes and socks next to the
fire they're not gonna dry out
completely but at least they'll be warm
when they put them on
use up the last of our berries the boys
are eating wild berry granola and i've
got some dehydrated breakfast skillet
here
well after my first night on the sea to
summit comfort light i really like it
that's uh that's the man i'm gonna be
using again what do you think of your
sleeping bags
they're nice aren't they
well boys you ready to hike back yeah
all right let's do it
ocean snack um
bladder or there's these little bubbles
on the end of the seaweed
and uh actually tastes good it's kind of
like
salty garden peas
oh you're so muddy dad
look at this as treacherous as this
trail is the view is amazing
maybe i do have to take you back today
oh yeah
we all need baths
oh i i think we found a deep hole here
here we're gonna get you up give me up
give me a hat
go watch out for that stream here nate
give me a hit
the forest of alaska from here in
whittier all the way down
south to about catch can are mostly rain
forest
it rains over 200 days a year
we get this incredibly lush thick
vegetation
but it's just an amazing ecosystem a wet
one
but it's pretty awesome
man down
we can see the car we made it oh
my shoulders are a little tender well
you guys want to get some food before we
head back
all right guys who wants ice cream we've
got cotton candy
moose flavor and caribou flavor which
one do you want couldn't pick a
more beautiful day today well i hope you
guys enjoyed this video as much as we
enjoyed filming it
if you guys want to see more outdoor
adventures hiking camping
survival videos that sort of thing don't
forget to click subscribe
to the outdoor boys youtube channel we
put out new videos every saturday
morning
thanks for watching guys if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching